okay so tenet is a pretty mind-bending
movie that deals with the complexities
of entropy
theoretical physics and the flow of time
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the ins and outs of the
science behind the film
and also giving our thoughts on how it
all works there will be heavy spoilers
here
so if you haven't had the time to check
out the movie yet then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video and please subscribe to
the channel for videos like this every
day
without the way this is the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul
now let's get into the science behind
tenet
okay so tenet subscribes to the theory
that there exists
only one timeline and that if one were
to travel back to the past
they would not be able to alter things
and instead would end up simply playing
into the events that happened so that
the future could follow the same course
this means that time is not malleable
and everything that will happen
will happen exactly how it's supposed to
in theoretical
physics there actually exists a manner
of thinking known as the block universe
theory
which states that all of time is
happening at once and we merely give it
its notion of the past
present and future because of our
inability to comprehend its vastness
it's something that fiction has toyed
with most notably dr manhattan
who was able to see every moment in his
life simultaneously
but the depths of it go far beyond comic
book characters
now time is very difficult to explain
i'll try my best to go over the block
universe theory with diagrams and
relatable things
but do bear with me before going into
everything though
we have to discuss what space time is
now space
time is the measurement of the three
dimensions of space
fused with time which creates a four
dimensional manifold
that can be carried across into
coordinates i'm going to be
predominantly using this image of a grid
in order to map out exactly what space
time is and how these building blocks of
it fall in line to create a precise
measurement
that we can understand i'm going to be
labeling this your day
i'm not spying on you don't don't check
behind the curtain
but once you get to grips with this
model it should hopefully
help you get your head around the entire
thing okay so
imagine this is actually your day mapped
out in the form of a cube
at 8 am you wake up so we would mark
down this time on the cube
and because we know the location of your
home because i am
spying on you we can mark down the exact
coordinates of this
giving us a precise moment of space time
once we also factor in today's date
now imagine each one of these cubes
within the cube
is a point in your day because we have
the location
and time that you are at a said location
we can map out precise coordinates
get off youtube you're supposed to be at
work no but we could mark out the entire
day
minute by minute hour-by-hour and create
a perfect picture of your routine
wait why why are the coordinates of when
you go to bed different or when you
wake up hey that that's my mom's house
no but that's pretty much space time in
as simplified a way as i can present it
now if we look at that entire block as
one day and then put it into a bigger
cube
we could actually map out the entirety
of your life day to day
with this potentially having precise
coordinates for every single moment of
your life
they even have a scene in interstellar
in which you can sort of see
every single moment laid out like this
and that's probably gonna give you a
much better understanding of the
the block universe theory than i ever
could because i
suck but you bring this all together on
a grander scale of not
just your life but every single thing in
the entire universe
and we have a complete map of everything
with all time happening at once
similar to molecules within a brick each
minute
each moment is helping to make up the
hull but our brains are just too
focused on the here and now to see the
bigger picture
now what the characters intended do is
that they reverse their entropy
in order to move backwards through time
typically we move forward
viewing the past as the past and the
future is the future
but the time inversion antenna allows
someone to change their perspective
so that they move backwards through the
block but what
is entropy exactly well the la times
spoke to theoretical physicist claudia
daram
and she had this to say about it entropy
is the measure of the level of order or
the level of information
there's a really fundamental law in
physics telling us that
entropy always increases on average
things get more and more disorganized
that's why we grow older our bodies get
slowly more and more disorganized
that's why it's much easier to destroy
something than to construct something
at the physical level if you have a box
and you put some gas in it
the gas will start taking up the whole
space it will spread and get more and
more disorganized
when entropy increases it means things
are becoming less and less organized
so entropy is pretty much the measure of
disorder in thermodynamics
for example if we smash some glass the
glass will fracture
but at no point will it move back
together and it will remain in this
disordered state
when discussing if it was possible to
invert the entropy of an object
claudia stated a fridge for instance is
a device where you lower the entropy so
that things are cooler
when things are cooler they have less
entropy if you think of ice
it's cooler and static and well
organized when you heat it up the
entropy increases
and it becomes liquid and it then
becomes a gas and it becomes
less organized a fridge or freezer
inverts it for you so we know that it's
very possible to have devices that
reverse
entropy but it doesn't mean that time
goes the other way in your fridge
when i put food in my fridge it doesn't
get fresher and fresher every day
but it's definitely possible to have a
device that decreases the entropy of an
object
the connection with having the internal
clock of that object going backwards
is a bit of an extrapolation that's part
of the poetry right
that's the fiction in the science
fiction so there are several things that
will happen
but the way the film presents it is
different to how we truly understand
entropy in real life
now in my research an interesting thing
that i found is that you would actually
need to take oxygen back with you
synolin was indeed correct however
where things would fall apart is through
our eyesight
we are able to see things because light
hits an object
and then bounces into our eyes however
if time were reversed
the light would travel backwards from
our eyes then hit the object before
traveling back to the light source
so we wouldn't actually see objects and
instead
we would simply see the light this would
mean that we couldn't actually see what
was around us
and thus moving would be extremely
difficult
sorry for ruining the entire film for
you when you watch it back now when
discussing the whole heat and freezing
thing as well that happens in the movie
claudia also dismissed this as not being
the case
stating that that's absolutely not what
would happen
it's like saying if something was white
it would become black
it's not like everything becomes the
opposite of each other the reason we
feel heat is because molecules in the
air hit a surface
that's what we feel the constant hitting
of particles on us
if time went backwards with respect to
us the molecules would hit the other way
but they would still hit we would still
feel them hitting
and we would still feel this notion of
heat so no the protagonist
wouldn't get hypothermia from being set
on fire
however this is just a film at the end
of the day and
i think it's you know it's a pretty cool
effect now
similar to interstellar though the
science isn't completely sound
i think it makes for a really fun ride
and i have to say that the more and more
i watch tennis
the more i appreciate its little
intricacies and use of time to explain
its story
claudia says that time travel is an
impossibility
but in this particular case it's not
really time travel
more inverting the notion of how we
perceive time
this means that things still do not
change but rather
we experience them in a totally
different manner due to the cause and
effect nature of the universe
being reversed the characters in the
movie are all behold into the structures
of time
and how things are in place and though
they believe that they have free will
when it boils down to it they really
don't thus
neil always has to sacrifice himself no
matter what and things have to happen
the way they have to happen i'm not
crying you're crying now
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
science behind the film and if there's
anything you'd like to add then please
drop a comment below
if you enjoy this video and want
something else tenant related to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of neil's timeline which is
gonna be linked at the end
don't forget we're also giving away a
free copy of the christopher nolan
collection
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random tomorrow on the 30th of september
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on the discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it till the end of the
video you've been the best i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
you